also an alle anderen hier hallo mein
name ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video ich trage
diese kappe hier nicht aus ästhetischen
gründen sondern einfach meine haare
gerade beschissen sind es ist raus wir
befinden uns heute auf der website erbin
dictionary falls ihr nicht wisst was das
ist ich habe ebenfalls überhaupt keine
ahnung ich habe vor ein paar tagen
einfach bei dem motto bild von einer
freundin von mir gesehen dass sie ihren
namen dort bei diesen dictionary
eingegeben hatte irgendwas kam so von
wegen poster girl läuft
und ja dass ich zeig euch mal ein
beispiel wir können hier oben
beispielsweise einfach mal computer
eingeben klicken dann hier auf computer
und dann steht ihr habt den finnischen
computer machine for downloading porno
sowie youtube derzeit drauf ist es bei
video jetzt wahrscheinlich direkt age
restricted und man darf sich nur auf 18
anschauen bei dem ihr zwei spielweise
auch mal iphone ein iphone billy maciel
cooles portugal ever made
naja
also so cooles setzt audi has only one
button and everything erstes operated by
dick touchscreen also ihr seht schon es
sind wirklich echte informationen die
hier eingeschrieben werden allerdings
jetzt halt nicht so wie bei wikipedia so
von wegen
das iphone wurde dann unter den wickelt
und es so und so alt und so viel wiegt
das und das und das kann man damit
machen sondern halt wirklich erben also
alles so er so ein bisschen
umgangssprachlich erklärt luca was
willst du jetzt eigentlich machen in dem
video hier wir schlagen heute die namen
von youtube an american dictionary nach
dabei muss ich allerdings sagen dass
jetzt nichts was ein geben könnte wie
beispielsweise von crafter weil bei
konkreter wird er mir nur anzeigen in
der antenne definitions vorkontrakte
1 anlegen sollte okay wenn ihr wollt
dass ich irgendwie mal in der nächsten
folge einen eigenen orden dictionary
artikel von crafter anlege dann lasst
man like da und schreibt vielleicht
schon mal definition in die kommentare
also sowas wie konkreter ist punkto
punkt und spaß ja das wäre tatsächlich
schon sehr passend suchen also nicht die
youtube namen von den leuten sondern die
vornamen das heißt wir fangen jetzt
beispielsweise an mit dem größten
youtube aller zeiten juli heißt felix
das heißt wir geben jetzt hier felix ein
klicken auf den ersten den ersten search
result und wir sehen top der finnischen
felix the person who has allowed dick
juli bei du hast einen grossen penis
außerdem pimp und außer dem posten
bekamen stoxx es wohl in some way
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal richtig
felix lkw felix kolbeck lka sind coole
djs falls ihr die camper
ich habe mir jetzt hier bei social
bleibt einfach mal so ein paar top
youtube-kanäle rausgesucht
übrigens hier pop socket gibt es bei mir
und es ist bald wieder verfügbar das
heißt wenn ihr doch unbedingt haben
wollte bleibt auf jeden fall aktiv check
vielleicht mal zwei drei tage den lukas
shop aus aber zurück zum thema und bevor
sich irgendwer beschwerden masse nur
werbung
guckt euch meine videos jahr an und es
ist mein job und ich arbeite jeden tag
dann natürlich mal hinter für werbung
davon nach revier heißt mit vornamen
sebastian und wenn wir sebastians
einfach mal eingeben kommen top
definitions die besten weg eine ist ein
cooles person you wanna be loved by you
on for strings in kuwait courage college
also re wie du bist
die netteste und coolste person die wir
alle ihr kennenlernen werden und du
wirst von allen geliebt auch an dich
schönegg seinem deren stelle mein kumpel
max lkw kran kräfte heißt er max mit
vornamen das heißt wir geben einfach mal
max ein und wir sehen schon short von
maximilian raschen termin in lodz teams
immer irgendwas mit drehen ist
eigentlich heißt der maximilian das
heißt ich gehe jetzt einfach mal
maximilian 1 und bei maximilian steht
die ultimate
ultimate what you like you motherfuckers
parteiwechsel million euro die maxime
million auf sex mit schickem everything
that no hay luca kannst du dich mit
deinen namen eintragen persons who are
the world oder string thing is highly
exclusive systems international european
able to be chuck norris entpuppen
wrestling weil trading chance' ich kann
tag norris beim armdrücken besiegen und
nebenbei noch shares verhandeln also
noch aktien handeln also an alle anderen
hier gegeben jetzt einfach mal nochmal
dagmara ein also den vornamen von debbie
und bei dagmara kommt the pretty girl
with the westin dagmara sayuri blond es
halt wirklich blond gefärbten ag ist auf
jeden fall blond meine very smart nice
to everyone apple dagmara istithmar
world you anything you von der ss
textilwerk race i don't think before
doing something der 2 days of pop diva
ok das heißt hier wird gesagt da die
briten geilen arsch sie ist berühmt und
sie ist das schönste mädchen was man
immer sehen wird aller zeiten
das ist doch mal ein tolles ende das was
ihr vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr noch
einen teil davon haben wollt wo ich mir
beispielsweise in eigenen artikel mache
oder wo ich noch mehr news übernahmen
suche dann lasst mann dessen like da ist
mich auf jeden fall mega freuen und
jetzt schreibt mal bitte in die
kommentare irgend eine kurze definition
für contractor also einfach kontraste
doppelpunkt und dann irgendwas dann kann
ich ja vielleicht beim nächsten mal
wirklich irgendwas anlegen sonst tut mir
leid dass das heutige video nicht so
lang geworden ist aber ich habe wirklich
übelsten stress gerade ich muss gleich
noch auto fahren das ist schon acht uhr
und das video kam es auch relativ spät
ihr findet hier trotzdem smiley
eingeblendet wenn er darauf klickt
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren also das
ist kostenlos und ihr verpasst keine
videos mehr und ich lade auch echt viel
geilen shit hoch und hier unten findet
ihr hängt ein anderes video eingeblendet
ist locker
halt komplette scheiße
macht nix